here are this week's top movies the  animals windows has begun we gave in  Coco and aspiring musician journeys with  a charming trickster to unlock the true  story behind his family's history  the new British Prime Minister must  decide how to lead his people when Nazi  forces approach in darkest hour do you  stop interrupting me while I am  interrupting you how do you think a  world come alive I can almost see and  hear them people Charles Dickens creates  a timeless tale that redefined a holiday  in the man who invented Christmas see  what's hot in theatres with this week's  fan tissa patient so what's your weekend  ticket going to be let us know by  commenting see you next time on weekend  ticket  [Music]